>> LOOK AT THAT.
LOOK AT THAT.
HAPPY WEDNESDAY, EVERYONE.
STOP IT.
WE GOT TO DO A SHOW.
IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK IN THE
FREE REPUBLIC OF FLORIDA.
THANK YOU FOR RECEIVING US WITH
OPEN ARMS.
EVEN AT THEY'RE COVERED WITH
BLACK SABBATH TATTOOS AND ABOUT
77 SUNSCREEN.
LET'S COVER SOME NEWS BEFORE WE
GET THE MONOLOGUE.
AN AMERICAN TRAPPED IN UKRAINE
FOR EIGHT MONTHS SAYS HE EVADED
RUSSIAN TROOPS BY PRETENDING TO
BE IRISH.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE WAS DRUNK.
COMEDIAN GALLAGHER SADLY HAS
PASSED AWAY AT AGE 76.
HIS FAMILY SCHEDULED A PRIVATE
CEREMONY FOLLOWED BY SMASHING
HIM WITH A GIANT HAMMER.
WE HAD TO SHOW THE PICTURE OF
THE WATERMELON.
>> AMAZON ANNOUNCED GIVING HIS
FORTUNE TO CHARITY PRAISE IT
HUNTER BIDEN TICKET GET MOST OF
HIS FORTUNE TO CHARITY, SUMMER
AND THE OTHER GIRLS DANCING THE
WEDNESDAY NIGHT SHIFT.
TEXAS IS SENDING A NEW BOX OF
MIGRANTS TO THE SANCTUARY CITY
OF PHILADELPHIA.
SPARKING OUTRAGE FROM MIGRANTS
WHO PACKED FOR MARTHA'S VINEYARD
.
QUOTE, THIS ISN'T WHAT I SIGNED
UP FOR SAID IT ONE REFUGEE NAME
IT BAIDOA WARWICK.
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AS IT
DID PROTECTING HEATING BILLS
WILL JUMP 28 PERCENT THIS WINTER
.
NOT AS LONG AS MY FINGER IS
AROUND TO BE POLLED SAID ERIC
SMALL WELL.
LET'S DO A MONOLOGUE THAT
DISCUSSED YOUR?
>> PEOPLE BELIEVING THE BLUE
STATES IN DROVES TO COME UP HERE
.
EVEN A AOC VISITED WITH HER
BOYFRIEND PERHAPS IT TO AIR OUT
HIS NASTY FEET.
LOOK AT THOSE THINGS.
LAST TIME I SOTILLET THAT THAT
UGLY I WAS WATCHING JURASSIC
PARK.
AND FOR THE MOST PART LET THE
LEADERS ARE TOO STUBBORN TO
ADMIT IT'S THEIR GARBAGE
POLICIES SENT PEOPLE FLEEING
LIKE CAT FROM THE COPS.
HERE IS THAT NEW YORK GOVERNOR
KATHY HOKE OH.
>> THE BRIGHT SPRING SPRING
GOVERNMENT BACK TO THE PEOPLE
AND OUT OF THE HANDS OF
DICTATORS.
WE ARE HERE TO SAY THAT THE ERA
OF TRUMP AND BIZZELL AND MLN AR
JUMP ON A BUS AND HEAD DOWN TO
FLORIDA WHERE YOU BELONG.
GET OUT OF TOWN.
YOU DON'T REPRESENT OUR VALUES.
YOU ARE NOT NEW YORKERS.
>> WE TOOK YOUR ADVICE AND HERE
WE ARE.
LET'S HOPE SHE DID NOT FOLLOW A
DOWN HERE ON HER BROOMSTICK.
IT SEEMS A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
TAKING HER ADVICE.
JUST NOT ABOUT HER EYEBROWS.
IT GIVES HER THAT SURPRISED LOO
ON HER FACE LIKE WHEN YOU
ACCIDENTALLY SIT DOWN ON A
CHILD'S TOY.
I SAID ACCIDENTALLY.
>> MAYBE SHE IS AS SHOCKED AS W
ARE THAT SHE ONE IF IT IS THE
BRASKA ANY HIGHER THEY WOULD
TURN INTO WINGS.
SHE'S THE EMBODIMENT OF THE FLA
OF THE LAST STINKY EVERYTHING
THEY THINK SHOULD BE A NEGATIVE
ABOUT FLORIDA IS SOMETHING IS
PEOPLE WHERE PROBABLY LIKE A RE
WHITE AND BLUE SPEEDO.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN GOVERNOR
DESANTIS ENDED THE COVID
LOCKDOWN AND OPENED UP
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS IN PLACE
LIKE NEW YORK SAID TO HAVE BLOO
ON YOUR HANDS.
WE GOT TO KEEP OUR KIDS AT HOME
AND MASKED UP AND DOUBLE ZOOM
AND A TRIPLE MASK IF JEFFREY
TOOBIN IS ON THE CALL BE BACK
WHILE FLORIDA WAS PUSHING TO GE
KIDS INTO SCHOOL LEARNING PLACE
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
RENAMING SCHOOLS INTO CHE
GUEVARA ELEMENTARY ALLERGY MEN
HI SOUNDS PRETTY GOOD.
>> THE RESULTS OF FLORIDA IS
DOING GREAT BUT KIDS AND OTHER
STATES CAN'T HAVE AND SUBTRACT
BECAUSE THEY'RE TO TWO GRADE
LEVELS BEHIND.
IT'S A BAD THE AVERAGE FRESHMAN
IS READING AT A JOY BEHAR LEVEL.
MEANWHILE, I JUST HIRED A
SIXTH-GRADER FROM FORT
LAUDERDALE TO MANAGEMENT ESTATE.
WHICH IS MOSTLY BRONZE COINS
FROM ROSEMAN CAPITAL.
THANKS TO BIDEN MY FOUR O ONE K
IS UP FOR A ONE NOT.
THE KIDS AND LOCKDOWN STATES
THAT THERE ARE SO STUPID THIS
YEAR'S MOST POPULAR BOY'S NAME
WAS BOZO.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET WHEN YOU
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT BELIEVED IN
GOVERNMENT MORE THAN THE PEOPLE
IT GOVERNS.
FLORIDA IS THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S GROUND ZERO FOR PARENTS
RIGHTS.
YOU DON'T HAVE A BEEF WITH DRAG
QUEENS YOU JUST DON'T WANT THEM
IN PRESCHOOL TEACHING THEM TO
WORK.
>> I SAY WAIT UNTIL IT'S
AGE-APPROPRIATE LIKE THE FIFTH
GRADE WHEN IT NEVER SEX
EDUCATORS TEACHING IN THE
PADDOCK ON THEM ON A BANANA
BLINDFOLDED.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A VOICE
IN YOUR EDUCATION AND FLOATED
THERE ON YOUR SIDE.
WHAT ABOUT LAW AND ORDER DURING
THE CUP--AGAINST AGAINST LOOTERS
.
WHAT WAS THAT?
SOMEBODY HAD A CORONARY
TRANSLATION, SHOOT THEM IF YOU
GOT THEM.
>> THE ONLY WAY TO REDUCE
LOOTING.
IN OTHER CITIES THE REDEFINED
THEFT AS WE JUST BE SURE AND
WHICH IS THE JUST IN FROM OF TH
IS IN.
YOU'RE DRIVING TO TIMES SQUARE
YOU WILL SEE THE SIGN.
YOU CAN'T WALK THROUGH TIMES
SQUARE AFTER BEING ASSAULTED BY
A DISNEY CHARACTER.
THANKS TO BILL AWAY FROM, MICKE
MOUSE IS BACK ON THE STREET
BEFORE YOU COULD SAY WINNIE THE
POOH.
WHO IS THE SIGN FOR?
THE ARMED CRIMINAL?
IT CAN'T BE THE AVERAGE THUG NE
YORK CAN'T READ.
SINCE HE LIKELY WENT TO THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IT'S A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF LIBERALISM THEY
CREATE MORE LAWS OF THE
LAW-ABIDING UNAWARE THAT
CRIMINALS ARE DEFINED BY NOT
FOLLOWING LAWS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEIR NEIGHBOR
JAILED.
AT NYC YOU DON'T GET A SLAP ON
THE REST WHEN YOU'RE CAUGHT YOU
GET A PAT ON THE BACK AND
RELEASED.
HANDCUFFS AND MORE IN MY BEDROO
THIS YEAR THAN THE NYPD HAS ALL
YEAR.
THAT'S HOW HE LIKES IT.
ALSO YOU EVER NOTICE HOW PEOPLE
WHO HATE FLORIDA SAY THE STATES
MAP LOOKS LIKE A?
SO WHAT MANHATTAN IS SHAPED LIK
IT HURT.
THE KIND YOU SEE IN A SIDEWALK
OUTSIDE STARBUCKS.
THEY CALL THAT A BEN T.
FLORIDA HAS GREAT BEACHES OF OF
FLIPTOP BABES IN THONGS AND
THANKFULLY MOST ARE WOMEN.
YET NOTHING LOOKS WORSE IN A
THONG THAN A CHICKEN HAS WHAT
LOOKS LIKE THE OUTLINE OF
FLORIDA AND HER BANANA HAMMOCK.
A NEW YORKER, THE BEACHES ARE A
CROSS BETWEEN ACC SUSHI BAR AND
A NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAM WAY
PASSED HEPATITIS C BY NOW IT'S
HEP LM NLP LAST AND FLORIDA YOU
GOT GORGEOUS WILDLIFE AND
TROPICAL BIRDS TWO DELIGHTFUL
DOLPHINS IN NEW YORK YOU GOT
PIGEONS WITH RAP SHEETS FISH
WITH ADDERALL ADDICTIONS AND
RATS WITH GANG TATTOOS AND EVEN
THEY ARE THINKING ABOUT RETIRIN
HERE.
AND YOU THEM?
CAN YOU BLAME THEM?
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
THAT'S A JUDGE LOVES TO TALK.
COHOST OF THE FIVE.
HE'S MAKING FLORIDA ARE BETTER
FOR WOMEN BLUSHING OVER HIS,
COHOST FOX AND FRIENDS WEEKEND.
THIS IS HER FIRST TRIP TO
FLORIDA WITHOUT THE ANKLE
MONITOR.
>> WHEN HER HURRICANE SEASON IS
HERE [INDISCERNIBLE]
JUDGE, IT'S KIND OF LIKE A
WIN-WIN.
PEOPLE COME FROM NEW YORK AND
ARE HAPPY AND I THINK LOCAL IS
HAPPY BECAUSE SHE KNOWS THAT
THERE ARE REPUBLICANS.
>> WHAT THE ONLY PEOPLE LEFT IN
NEW YORK ARE DEMOCRATS THERE
HAPPY THEY CAN JUST AFFORD THE
24-DOLLAR BANANAS.
>> HAS A FAR AS THAT WAS FROM
ANOTHER SHOW.
IN ADDITION TO THAT SHE WANTS I
NO REPUBLICANS TOO FEEL
COMFORTABLE IN NEW YORK.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN LAW AND ORDER
SHE DOES NOT WANT TO DEAL WITH
YOU.
GO TO FLORIDA OR ANOTHER STATE
THEY BELIEVED THAT CRIMINALS BE
CRIMINALS AND THAT'S THE END OF
IT.
>> THAT'S IT AND THAT'S ALL I
GOT TO SAY.
>> YOU LOOK GREAT AS ALWAYS I'M
GLAD MY WORKOUT HAS REALLY
HELPED YOU.
>> IT HAS YOU HAVE A LOT OF KID
ARE YOU PLANNING ON HAVING MORE?
MOVING HERE?
>> WE CONSIDER THAT ALTHOUGH WE
MOVED TO TENNESSEE FLORIDA WAS
IN THE WRITING SHOULD BE IN THE
WRITING THINGS ARE SO BAD IN NE
YORK THAT ALL THE REPUBLICANS
LEFT NEW YORK AND MOVED TO
FLORIDA.
>> YET LEE SELDEN WITH NO
REPUBLICANS ALMOST WINS.
>> BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE--
LIBERALS WITH ANY SANITY
SAY I DON'T WANT TO GET MUGGED
LIKE MY TAXES TO GO TO SOMETHING
.
MY BOY SHOULD NOT BE TOLD
THEY'RE A GIRL.
AT THAT STUFF EVENTUALLY ADDS UP
.
HAD MAY THERE'S HOPE FOR NEW
YORK BUT I DON'T THINK ANYONE
HERE IS GOING BACK THERE TO HEL
IT.
>> WATCHING THIS GAME FROM NEW
YORK AND HIS LOWBALL I HAVE AT
THEIR YOUNG PEOPLE LEFT NEW YOR
BECAUSE THEY CAN PUT UP WITH
BEING MUGGED AND CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES ABOUT THEM AT A
CERTAIN AGE IT'S LIKE NOW.
I GAVE YOU THE BEST YEARS OF MY
LIFE I'M OUT OF THIS
RELATIONSHIP IT'S LIKE LEAVING
AN ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP.
>> OUT OF THE GETTY YOUNG PEOPL
AS LIKE I COULD PUT UP WITH BIG
MILD I DON'T THINK SO BUT THE
MOCKING I CAN'T PUT UP WITH OR
THAT I AM SICK OF IS THE STATE
INCOME TAX.
EVERYBODY HERE IS SMILE LIKE
THAT'S GREAT BUT I ALSO WORRY I
MIGHT HAVE FIT IN BECAUSE I'M
NOT THE SMILE HE ASKED ABOUT
MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE I'M SICK O
BEING STOLEN FROM HIM THE STATE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I WOULDN'T MIND GETTING HAVE MY
INCOME TAKEN AWAY IF I SAW
SOMETHING FROM IT.
BUT I DON'T.
>> YOU DON'T GO OUTSIDE AND IT
SMELLED HORRIBLE ALL THE TIME.
>> I LIKE THAT.
I ENJOY THE NEW YORK SMELLS
BECAUSE HEIGHTS MINE.
>> I WOULDN'T EVEN TOUCH WATER
FOR DAYS.
>> GUTFELD, I HAVE AN ISSUE WIT
SOMETHING YOU SAID YOU HAD THE
GALL AS A MARRIED MAN SEGA
DIDN'T MIND GIVING AWAY HALF OF
YOUR MONEY.
AS IF YOU HAD A HAVE TO GIVE.
THAT'S HILARIOUS.
IF SHE STILL TAKING IT ALL.
WHATEVER.
>> WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE NEW
YORK IS A NICE PLACE TO VISIT
AND I WILL NEVER LIVE THERE.
WE NEED TO AS REPUBLICANS OR
CONSERVATIVES OR ADULTS WHO CAN
ACTUALLY DO THINGS IN FRONT OF
THE CAMERA, WE NEED TO START
TEACHING THESE LIBERALS HOW TO
SPEAK BECAUSE I'M RUNNING OUT O
IDEAS.
WE GET COME ALL OF OF JOE JUST
SIT BACK AND WATCH BUT THE NEW
SHE CAN'T TALK EITHER AND SHE
HAS THAT THING WITH HER HAND
WHERE SHE TRIES TO PUSH HER WAY
THROUGH HER STUFF AND THEN
THEY'RE GONNA LEAVE TO FLORIDA
THEY'RE GONNA GO WHICH TELLS ME
THAT SHE DOESN'T EVEN BELIEVE [
BLEEP ]
WHAT SHE SAYS.
>> I HAVE TO SAY THIS STUFF BUT
PLEASE TAKE ME WITH YOU THEY
CANNOT BELIEVE THAT ANYONE WAS
BITTEN IN NEW YORK LATELY IS
LIKE THIS IS GREAT.
THIS IS AWESOME.
UNLESS OF COURSE YOU'RE A
CRIMINAL WHO JUST GOT ARRESTED
AND THE COP SAYS WHERE WOULD YO
LIKE US TO DROP YOU OFF THAT TH
ONLY WAY YOU CAN STOP A CRIMINA
IS IF THEY STEP IN HUMAN POOP
AND SLIP.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD HELPFUL TIP
.
I SURROUND MY ENTIRE APARTMENT
WITH HUMAN POOP.